Quiero hacer una corrección rápida al último
video, aunque realmente no afecta el aprendizaje
del contenido, pero sólo quiero asegurarme de
que entiendas que me equivoqué un poco en las
matemáticas del video anterior. Dije que este
era el estado de las cosas hace 300,000 años.
Hablábamos del Big Bang, que ocurrió hace 13,7
mil millones de años, y luego hablé del estado
de las cosas en el que estaríamos, quizás a 30
millones de años luz de distancia del borde del
universo observable actual, y dije que esto fue
hace unos 300,000 años después del Big Bang. De
eso hablé en el último video, ese fue nuestro
punto de partida, cuando el fotón comenzó a
viajar desde este punto y, obviamente, el universo
siguió expandiéndose. El fotón viajó cada vez más,
pero todavía había más y más camino que recorrer
a medida que el universo se expandía, a medida que
se expandía todo el espacio, pero esto es 300,000
años después del Big Bang. Ahora, mi cerebro,
porque no estaba pensando muy bien que digamos,
dijo "Esto fue hace 13,400 millones de años",
eso es lo que dije incorrectamente
casi al final del video anterior,
y dije que esto fue hace 13,400 millones
de años; y eso está mal porque si esto
fue hace 13,400 millones de años esto habría
ocurrido 300 millones de años después del Big
Bang. Pero estamos hablando de sólo 300,000
años después del Big Bang, así que no habría
quitado tantos lugares decimales en los miles
de millones. La respuesta correcta sería que
es un poco menos de 13,700 millones de años; ni
siquiera habría tenido una cifra significativa,
así que esto es todavía aproximadamente 13,700
millones de años. Así que sólo quería hacer esa
corrección, fue un pequeño error. No debería
haber visto esto como 300 millones de años,
esto es apenas 0.3 millones de años, ni siquiera
cambia la precisión de este número de aquí.
Sólo quería aclarar eso, pero con suerte no
afectará demasiado tu comprensión del tema.